it is this really broad and inclusive
community if you join like the longevity
subreddit for example there's like a
hundred thousand people that are always
talking about this stuff
there's a
i mean family isn't the right word to
use but it really feels like this
collectivist sort of like uh very
inclusive and welcoming communities and
the blockchain space is the same hello
and welcome to the chicky science show
where in this video i had the great
pleasure of speaking with tyler galato
co-founder and chief scientific officer
at molecule a collaborative platform to
accelerate the process of bringing novel
therapeutics to patients and who has
more recently co-initiated feta dao the
world's first decentralized intellectual
property collective funding research
into human longevity here we discuss
both these projects and how they will
aid the future of longevity research say
hi tyler thank you for joining me today
and welcome to the chica science show
thanks for having me it's an absolute
pleasure to be here
thank you i'm so my first question for
you before we talk about all of the
amazing work you're doing with feta dao
i wanted to ask you first because you
initially uh studies biochemistry at
university as the guys so i'm very
curious as to what was your interest
into research and science and then how
did you make that kind of transition
from researching biochemistry into
exploring this world of blockchain
technology
yeah so i mean i started my career well
not even my career my interest developed
at quite a young age my sister was born
when i was five years old and she had a
sort of a respiratory virus for the
first like year of her life
or some respiratory condition and she
spent a lot of time in the hospital and
so i think at a young age i sort of had
an imprinting experience in in hospitals
and with physicians that um yeah in my
immature young mind like these were
people that were helping my sister and
that had a big effect on me i thought i
wanted to be a physician for
yeah i would say
up until i was in my my early 20s so
initially exploring biochemistry was
really just what i was viewing is like a
pre-med sort of sort of education course
in the united states
during that time i also spent a lot of
time in hospitals so i was working as a
nurse aide for example
during my summers and also when i was in
school really spending a lot of time
not only just around doctors but just
trying to understand how the healthcare
system works at a high level and
i think i had some early experiences uh
particularly in the context of the u.s
healthcare system where i i realized
that there were
yeah a number of things that were sort
of sub-optimal in terms of how patients
are treated how care is accessed you
know why some people are able to get
care and why other people weren't and i
found this to be to be somewhat
frustrating so increasingly i think
when i was actually at university i
started to really enjoy my my
biochemistry classes i became really
interested in genetics and i started to
feel like i potentially would have a
more fulfilling career being able to
let's say
yeah i mean i'm not sure if this is the
right way to put it but making broader
contributions
if i really explored the the sciences so
yeah during that time um i went to like
a small liberal arts school from
university they didn't have let's say
they don't have a medical school they
didn't have really well-established
laboratories but during the time that i
was there
research was becoming i think an
increasingly important part of what the
university was trying to position
towards and i had the opportunity quite
early on to get involved with um yeah
some interesting next-gen sequencing
approaches we were actually doing
projects studying the um microbiome of
horseshoe crab eggs which i can go into
more or less depth if you're interested
in hearing about that
um
yeah and through that this was the first
time i think that year was the year that
the university got next-gen sequencers i
was one of the first students to be able
to use those um and then that actually
led me on sort of an interesting
research path
first into cancer therapeutics um which
was actually linked to the horseshoe
project strangely there was this
bacteria that was affecting um horseshoe
crab egg populations that was cytotoxic
and we realized could have some
potential anti-cancer properties
i got deeper and deeper into sort of
oncology and experimental therapeutics
in the context of oncology with a focus
on pancreatic cancer glioblastoma and
neuroendocrine tumors and then through
that um also became interested in
general in in biogerontology and and the
the science of aging which i saw as this
really interesting sort of new paradigm
through which we could approach
really medicine in a different way we
could take a more preventative approach
focus on really maintaining health as
opposed to treating it and maybe make
headway into treating all age-related
diseases
during this time i was also really
interested in sort of the the
macroeconomics of pharma and drug
development how drugs actually come to
market what the incentives are
um and i think yeah there was an article
that came out maybe in 2017
that was penned by um it was a couple of
people from goldman sachs and the
article was titled is curing disease a
sustainable business model and i found
this really provocative and and really
speaking to what i saw as some of the
core systemic problems that exist and
the incentives that exist around drug
development in the united states and
increasingly i felt like i didn't
necessarily
yeah i was i started to become quite
interested in this problem so this
problem of like there are some core
let's say problems with incentive
structures and
let's say innovation in the
pharmaceutical development ecosystem
uh i felt like that was a problem that i
was really interested in trying to work
on but i i wasn't really sure how
and then i sometime later met
my co-founder at molecule paul kolhas
who came from a sort of yeah economics
background but particularly with a focus
on on blockchain and and how
decentralized systems were being
beginning to be leveraged to create
let's say new incentive structures to
allow like collaboration or in some
cases decentralized governance
um yeah and we founded a company this is
like maybe three and a half years ago
now that was really focused on trying to
leverage these technologies
decentralized technologies and web 3
technologies to change in some incentive
structures um in in drug development and
to change let's say how how the public
actually interacts with intellectual
property around therapeutics
oh thank you for that explanation so in
terms of um the problems in drug
development what what actually are the
major problems that you're trying to
solve
with molecule
yeah the there's a number i mean so over
over the past 30 or so years the way
that drug development happens has really
fundamentally changed so the
pharmaceutical drug development pipeline
from sort of discovery to market used to
be vertically integrated it used to be
that a pharmaceutical company did you
know sort of drug discovery
um pre-clinical development
in some cases clinical trials all the
way through to market in-house
and over time the roi so the the the
sort of um
yeah the the profit of how profitable
this process was really started
declining there's a number of theories
about why this is but in 2020 the the
roi on internal r d for pharmaceutical
companies raised reached about zero
percent meaning that it just simply
wasn't profitable to do
in-house drug development so what you
had start to happen was this change in
the let's say macroeconomic landscape
where it was highly incentivized for
pharmaceutical companies to really start
outsourcing intellectual property from
from academia so i think in the past
five years it was something like more
than half of the top selling drugs that
are that that have been brought to
market originated at universities where
you know in in maybe 20 years ago it was
it was maybe something like 10 so
there's been this really
really big shift in how drugs are being
developed and
the problems relate to the cost of
bringing a drug to market which is
you know depending on the estimate and
who you speak to or what the sort of
study metrics are anywhere from on the
low end 800 million dollars to on the
high end 2.8 billion dollars according
to a i think like a landmark tough study
that is often referenced
and that means that in order to develop
a drug there needs to be a really strong
let's say financial incentive it's very
difficult for a university or an
academic or
really most organizations on the planet
to have access to the capital that is
required to bring a drug to market and
what that means is that
when a pharmaceutical company is looking
at whether or not a drug should be
developed
the metrics aren't really you know what
is the impact on patients or is this
something that is going to cure disease
they tend to be driven largely by
whether or not the finance the
pharmaceutical company will be able to
recoup the cost and potentially profit
from the investment that it's made
the problem with that is that there are
a lot of let's say rare diseases there
are a lot of therapies antibiotics for
example that don't really
meet that sort of criteria from from a
profitability standpoint let's say and
therefore the incentives to develop
these
um are quite minimal so a lot of what
we've been doing with molecule is trying
to figure out how can we bring together
communities
whether these be patient advocacy
communities whether they be communities
of researchers whether they be
organizations
you know philanthropic organizations
and unify them in such a way that they
can fund the development of these
therapeutics that maybe pharmaceutical
companies aren't interested in
and through that funding also have
ownership in the intellectual property
that results from from these projects
and
the idea is that by creating a situation
where
a patient or a group of patients or
patient advocacy groups actually become
the governors and owners of intellectual
property that the incentives to develop
these things somewhat change and the
example that i often give when i speak
about this is you know what would it
look like if insulin was collectively
owned and governed by diabetics how
would it be priced what would access to
that look like
how would a patient behave differently
from a corporation for example so these
are the sort of that's the high level
engineering question and then there's a
number of let's say technical
implementations legal frameworks um and
design frameworks that you can create to
try to encourage that behavior to try to
get people to fund these things and to
do so with some sort of incentive
cool thank you for elaborating on that
so i mean do you have any examples at
the moment of why you've taken any drugs
and helped to mediate this process
yeah so there's a couple this is also it
took us roughly i mean molecules existed
for three years it probably took us two
years of of trial and error around
many different components of what we
were building to try to get to something
that really made sense and that we could
work with we did some early early trials
actually with i'm doing the
decentralized funding of microdosing
experiments with psilocybin for the
treatment of anxiety and depression um
weren't able to raise a huge amount of
money there but managed to
do a little bit still very fringy at the
time i think in terms of like the
technology that we're using but the
current implementation of a lot of our
design thinking and the tools that
molecule has been building are are
really in the form of
vitadao which is a decentralized
collective for funding longevity
therapeutics
using the same framework so basically
bringing together a large community of
enthusiasts researchers anyone who's
interested in the aging space and i
suppose this is a you know with aging
everyone as a patient right so i mean
this is sort of the broadest uh i would
say implementation of this really
possible
um
and we have basically is a live
organization that is actively has raised
around i believe at
current ether prices eight million
dollars and is deploying that actively
into into research projects and the
first project that we have this
happening with is a repurposing project
at the university of copenhagen with uh
morton shelby knutson
who has basically
he had exclusive access um to the danish
health systems uh
medical records histological records and
for subscription records which i believe
it's roughly 3.5 billion data points
covering something like 3 500
prescriptions on about 5 million people
over 40 years so this really really
robust
really really robust database
and they spent um i think roughly two
years looking at the data in this in
this database and trying to work out
whether or not there were some number of
previously approved therapeutics that
had been
implicated in extending health span and
lifespan so
let's say these therapeutics were highly
conserved for example among populations
of centenarians and supercentenarians
and now they're basically working
backwards
from this data in humans to understand
the novel like if there's a
let's say off targetism of action here
in these therapeutics that's
contributing to
um this pro-longevity effect and that's
really the first project that we're
working on but we're currently
evaluating
i think between
20 and 30 additional projects and again
this this beaded out experiment if you
call it that really began
about 12 weeks ago so the hope is to
really get this sort of yeah flywheel
spinning and a lot of projects funded
under this framework in the next
in the next like six months
wow no that's really exciting and well
you beat me to my next question which
was about feeds out and so i guess
before we go further into exploring what
futado is i think it would definitely
help probably myself and also my viewers
if we just kind of explain um or if you
can explain
what you mean by blockchain and what is
like decentralized technologies and or
even at the tao
yeah definitely so i mean these are
something i often say that like speaking
to someone about about blockchain it's
like speaking about god it's like
everyone has a different
conceptualization of what these things
are the media obviously plays a strong
role as well and sort of like
there's some confusion between
blockchain and cryptocurrency and and
yeah but i think the easiest way to to
think about a blockchain is simply a
it's a decentralized database that is
not controlled by any one individual
there's a lot of redundancy in it and
therefore it's immutable it's
permissionless and it's trustless so
basically the way blockchain works is
that
it's a it's a ledger it's basically
making a record of transactions that
occur using this decentralized
peer-to-peer network
and every block that is created contains
all of the previous transactions that
have ever occurred
within that system and so
there's this
sort of immutability to it because these
these blocks are linked together every
time uh yeah i don't know how in how
much technical detail i want to go here
because that i think could actually
become more confusing than less
confusing but the the easiest way to
think about it is that it's basically a
decentralized peer-to-peer network that
is essentially more or less a database
of transactions and then there's
different implementations of blockchain
so i mean bitcoin for example is the
bitcoin blockchain is is fairly simple
in its design it's just this sort of
decentralized ledger of transactions and
it basically allows people around the
world to
exchange in this cryptocurrency which is
bitcoin but then you have things like
ethereum which brings some level of
programmability into a blockchain so
instead of just being
let's say a decentralized database it
would be like having a decentralized
database where all of the cells within
that database can actually run a
computer program
and this increases the complexity of
what that blockchain can do quite a lot
and in the case of ethereum those
computer programs are smart contracts
which can be programmed to do a lot of
different things
cryptocurrencies are just the
sort of let's say the transactional
currency in essence that these
blockchains use to verify
transactions and to allow people to use
the network
um what's really interesting for me and
where
these systems become quite interesting
are not necessarily around the transfer
of value or around let's say
exchanging in a cryptocurrency between
two parties it's actually around
different designs for cryptocurrencies
that are not necessarily
financially driven or or transaction
based in that sense it's when you get
into what is called tokenization so
there's sort of your very common
cryptocurrencies and i think the things
that most people will be familiar with
like bitcoin and ethereum but then you
also have all of these projects many of
which are building on the ethereum
blockchain that create tokens that have
a certain utility
and those tokens can allow you to do
things for example like vote or
participate in governance
um around a structure or an organization
and this is pretty intrinsic to
what vitadao is and how it works so vida
dao in essence is a
is a dao which is a decentralized
autonomous organization and the easiest
way to think about this would be it's
basically a membership collective it's a
organization of people that come
together in this case around funding
longevity research but the doll is is
nothing more than the organization of
people from around the world who have
some common goal and instead of having a
sort of top-down management structure
like a company would have for example
it is governed through technology in in
this case a smart contract where any
member who possesses
some number of these tokens
can make a proposal and can vote on
proposals that are made
and those those proposals when they're
approved become the bylaws or
essentially the
rules of that organization
um this is particularly interesting
because it in this case it means that
you don't have a structure
where one person or a centralized entity
is able to control the organization or
able to exert a lot of pressure on it
instead you have a community of people
who are coming to consensus around
something and the way that that is
insured and mediated is really through a
technology a smart contract as opposed
to let's say uh an executive board or
something like that
well i think that's really helped i'm
not sure if that was i i i still feel
like there's like too much complexity
like
i wish i could yeah i'm always i think
this is a huge struggle like i'm always
thinking of
what is the simplest way to explain
these things to to anyone so that they
would immediately get it and i think
because uh
i'm often quite in my head about this
stuff right like we're thinking about
these technologies quite a lot i would
say the easiest way to think about it
would almost be like a dao is like a
you know a membership community that you
can join and everybody basically has
voting rights and those voting rights
determine how the organization functions
okay now that really has helped and i'm
on from that point i do agree that there
does seem to be quite a large learning
curve to understanding these different
terms behind blockchain technologies and
that's just wondering because as we'll
go on to um what featured i was
effectively trying to do is fundraise um
academic research and so um for those
academics who maybe don't have
so much of an understanding about
blockchain do you think do you think
that's going to be a bit of a
barrier to recruiting more people into
the ecosystem and how do you foresee
trying to mitigate that
definitely so i i mean you know we've
thought a lot about this and and you
know in the beginning there was i think
a lot of conversation like
i don't inherently view vitadell as a
crypto based organization and i think
this is a problem that a lot of
blockchain projects have it's like the
blockchain part of the front and center
and often
what they're actually doing or the
mission the vision gets lost in the
complexity of the blockchain stuff in
vitadao's case the blockchain is simply
a tool in a tool set that enables a
certain
a certain outcome which in this case is
bringing together a decentralized
community of people around a common goal
i would say
before the pandemic one thing that's
really interesting is that i would say
your average person knew a lot less
about blockchain because of things like
sort of nft craze and how yeah how
front and center the markets have been
i've been really surprised by
let's say that the level of
understanding that your average academic
even has around blockchain technologies
more universities are
are looking at these technologies quite
seriously pharmaceutical companies you
know the vaccine rollout for example was
using some level of blockchain in the
sort of supply chain optimization so
these things are going from being what i
think were fringier concepts five years
ago to being quite mainstream that said
it still is is an onboarding hurdle and
i think the blockchain space also also
suffers from a legitimacy problem
there's a there's a huge it's an
unregulated space it's like the early
days of the internet in some cases and
so you see every variety of project use
case scam etc unfolding and i think a
lot of people
tend to the things you hear about maybe
are these speculative bubbles or you
hear about you know crazy volatility in
markets and these things create a
certain stigma and they create a certain
barrier um to onboard people but this is
something we're always trying to work on
how do we simplify our language
how do we simplify the value proposition
and i think what will happen is that
dals themselves will go from being
this crypto thing to
essentially the sort of terminology like
if i said to you a non-profit foundation
a company or a dao people will
understand what those three things are
and they won't be thinking so much about
the blockchain components that that
enable dials to operate
um but yeah it's a really good point
it's it's a
it's
difficult
in many cases to be able to quickly give
the one minute elevator pitch on like
what this is and why it's valuable
um for sure
well no thank you for that and so
obviously leading on from that um you
are trying to
raise money to be able to fundraise
early research in the longevity space
and so how does that fundraising
actually work and given as you kind of
mentioned how the value of these
different uh cryptocurrencies in this
case is the theater tokens they may
fluctuate in value does that like affect
how much um like money you have to give
to different researchers
so the way the initial fundraise work
there's many different ways to fundraise
in in crypto
and the way that you fundraise typically
has some effect on the type of community
that ends up forming around the the
project that you're trying to create and
so the way that we wanted to do it was
what is called a fair launch it's a it's
a common term in the crypto space but
probably not known to anyone who's who's
not somewhat deep in it and what what it
means is basically you have so vita dal
basically created uh some number of
tokens in our case it's
64 million tokens which is actually the
the life span in minutes of jean-claude
who's like the the longest-lived woman
on earth so you create some
that long as the person on earth and so
you create some number of tokens in this
case 64 million 10 of those tokens were
sold in an auction
to
basically anyone who wanted to be a
member of vitadell and the team that
built vita dial didn't determine the
price or how much we were raising
actually the initial community by
creating bids and basically specifying
how many tokens they want to purchase
created the the market cap and the sort
of the amount that we would fundraise we
had a we had a certain target
which was actually quite low initially
it was was less than than a million
dollars and
as long as that goal was exceeded
the the entity would form sort of like a
kickstarter where if you don't reach
that target everyone's money is returned
in doing that this 10 of tokens that
were sold were auctioned to about i
think it was like 635 participants
something like that
and now that community that fundraised
and and purchased these these governance
tokens
basically also controls the entire dial
they have access to the remainder of the
90 of tokens and even the team that
created vita dal for example needed to
make a proposal for that community that
now governs the dao to give us tokens
for example to be able to participate in
governance so it was really
it was truly an example of
decentralizing a community early on to
you know away from a team and to a to a
group of stakeholders
we raised through that auction what at
the time was about 5.1 million dollars
and then some portion of the treasury
was kept in ether which has a certain
amount of volatility um and now that is
worth about i believe eight million
dollars and what media is doing is
slowly
selling that um ethereum into stable
coins so into usdc
which have no volatility whatsoever so
the the money that vita doll has raised
will be converted into a stable coin
that will not fluctuate and so that
treasury exists there to continue
funding research now the other component
to this is that now the dow is still
sitting on
um you know i i don't know exactly how
much it is let's say it's like 45
million vita tokens or something like
that at this point those vita tokens can
be
given to
researchers anyone that wants to join
the dow in exchange for their work so we
use this as an incentive to motivate
people to join the organization to
contribute to evaluating projects
sourcing projects educating the
community and they can also be sold in
subsequent financing rounds to enable
the dow to raise
more money but at the end of the day
their function is actually as a
governance token this isn't a
cryptocurrency in the sense that it's
not something that is meant to be
you know used as a store of value or a
transaction of
of of money it's something that allows
anyone who's interested in vita dial
around the core mission to actually
engage in in governance decisions and to
participate and to vote and to have a
voice in the community
so that
the
instability issue that is intrinsic to a
lot of cryptocurrencies is not a problem
for us from a fundraising perspective
um because our treasury is kept in is is
you know being moved into stable coins
and while vita the token does have a
value on secondary markets the goal
isn't to
[Music]
you know some
even if that price is quite stable over
time or even if it drops or even if it
goes up there's unknown of those tokens
that exist to be able to do subsequent
rounds of fundraising but the economic
mechanism through which vitadell
ultimately wants to become sustainable
is actually through
its investments into projects and the
resulting intellectual property so in
some way you can see the initial auction
as like a bootstrapping mechanism that
allows us to raise some money to really
begin funding projects and then over
time
those projects should actually mature to
a point of being
somewhat commercializable or you know it
be able to generate you know some amount
of revenue for for the dell to continue
funding longevity research and creating
this sort of circular economy
oh no that was a really good explanation
and so i guess to help i'm explaining
feeds it a little bit further um i'd be
good to kind of walk through the example
that's already started which is the
first fundraising of the project from
the university of copenhagen and so um
would you be able to um elaborate a bit
more on how what happens during that
transfer fund and how you then acquire
intellectual property rights and then
how that is kept updated and then
eventually i guess down the line used
and
commercialized upon
yeah so i mean it's fairly there's a
little bit of complexity to it but
there's also i think a lot of bridging
in of real world processes that would
happen exactly if the pharmaceutical
company for example was was doing a
sponsored research agreement with the
university so basically what happens is
beta dal
with the with the example of copenhagen
this project was identified they had an
interest in raising uh 250 000
they scoped out a series of experiments
which in in this case is initially
testing these therapeutics that i
described earlier
in
drosophila melanges or so in fruit flies
and then later in in human cells looking
at a variety of for example
dna repair proteins p53 a number of
things that might have some that these
drugs might have some implication on
from a from a biochemical perspective
they scope out these experiments and
basically vitadao creates what's called
a sponsored research agreement
where
we we basically say we will fund this
course of experiments in exchange for
ownership of the intellectual property
that results from those experiments now
some of the complexity here is that
academics don't often know especially in
the early stages what the
you know let's say the path to ip looks
like for the project they don't
necessarily know what the commercial use
case is for the project so we have a
group of people within the vitadock
community in the context of what we call
working groups this is almost like a
department within vitadell it contains
subject matter experts this can be
people who have a background in biotech
in dc and pharma academics phds postdocs
the community is open to anyone who
basically has a skill and wants to to
help patient
and they help determine with legal
counsel so we also have a legal working
group that consists of ip lawyers people
who have worked in licensing
they helped create with the academic and
often with the tech transfer office in
some cases if necessary um what the sort
of ip agreement will look like this is
basically then agreed to uh but then you
have another problem which is that a dao
is a jurisdictionless entity
that exists on the ethereum blockchain
it's not a company it doesn't have an
address and so this is now quite a
foreign
uh engagement for a university it's
something that is quite novel so how do
you how do you overcome this
and so what is actually done there's
there's two things that are done the
dial can elect in let's say a very
simple implementation the dial can elect
agents or representatives or create spvs
special purpose vehicles to engage in
these sort of legal agreements in a
rather vanilla way with the university
but what molecule has been building and
what i think is quite interesting is is
basically taking these these
these contracts or research agreements
and actually attaching them to what we
call an ipnft um people might have heard
of nfts from the from the art space in
the music space you know you see people
are spending
incentives absurd amounts of money for
for like what looks to be a jpeg
but nfts are actually a really powerful
technology um there it's basically a
non-fungible token which means that
unlike a bitcoin which is you know
infinitely divisible to an extent maybe
not infinitely but divisible quite a lot
um a non-fungible token is something
that can't be divided and therefore it's
really suitable for representing a
real-world asset you could make a
non-fundable token of a deed to a house
for example
and this actually allows the doll to
hold that intellectual property
in a smart contract implementation so
basically the way it works is
the dao and the university engage in a
regular sort of
legal agreement the way they would with
any sort of company or organization but
in this case that legal agreement is
attached to an nft and then held within
the dial and now you have basically
this this nft that can be transacted and
sold you can you know basically do do
anything with it in the concept in the
context of the cryptocurrency space but
it can also be held by a dal sold on in
the future um yeah by an entity that
either wanted to buy it on the
blockchain or could for example that
same legal agreement could move off
chain and be out licensed by let's say a
biotech company for example
okay so there are options to take it off
once it's joined effectively
yeah and so that's at the that's really
at the
at the decision of whoever is owning or
stewarding the the nft so in in this
case avidadel said that hey we're
interested in selling this this nft
which again is just a proxy for the
intellectual property that the project
is producing they could do that in a
transaction where they they moved it off
chain but it could also for example
be be bought by let's say another doll
or a group of individuals that said hey
we're interested in funding this or yeah
we want to to you know purchase this for
x or y reason and i think although it's
quite early what you're going to see
happening over the next
let's say five years is the creation of
many different dials and many different
therapeutic areas with different use
cases and design implementations
and you're going to start to get this
sort of you know web 3 driven drug
development system where it will be very
easy to transfer ip to transact in ip um
yeah they'll be molecule for example is
building a marketplace for ipnfts and
this is the sort of thing that we want
to enable very quickly for example a
community to come together let's say you
brought together i don't know
a group of people around huntington
huntington's disease for example and we
want to be able to allow researchers to
very quickly mint nfts of the research
projects specify the sort of licensing
terms and then rapidly enable these
communities that are being built with
their own incentive mechanisms their own
funding frameworks to very quickly fund
those research projects and have
exposure to the intellectual property um
again very early but this is the sort of
long-term thinking around this
no it sounds really exciting and so in
terms of the actual projects what kind
of longevity projects are you looking
for
so the communities i mean i i would say
we're somewhat agnostic
to like if you wanted to think about
aging in the context of like hallmarks
for example i would say we're quite
agnostic to to the hallmarks that we're
focusing on
but um because of the
because of the nature of vitadao and
this idea that we're trying to create a
vehicle that's self-sustaining and
itself has some longevity they should be
projects that have some ip component or
some potential to commercialize that
commercialization doesn't need to be
driven by
let's say profitability it just needs to
be the sort of thing where
there ultimately has to be some way for
the dial to sustain itself so they tend
to be the projects tend to be projects
that are drug development focused or
biomarker focused or diagnostic focused
we wouldn't we likely wouldn't fund very
early stage basic research looking at
something fundamental that wasn't
ultimately trying to create something
that let's say would have a strong
impact on patients or consumers very
directly
the
you know there is a community of people
that make up the working groups and
everybody has their own
you know they're mostly academics they
have their own biases and their own sort
of you know where they come from in the
aging space and ultimately like
yeah i suppose they're
if you went and surveyed the whole
community you would probably find some
sort of preferential breakdown of like
what people are really interested in
um
but yeah it's it's pretty it's pretty
broad i mean there's there's also
because it's a decentralized collective
there's these other things that we could
sort of do that i think are quite
interesting but are still somewhat early
like decentralized clinical trials for
example or looking at for example if you
have a community of thousands of people
that are able to you could do things
with like yeah that are maybe not
focused on commercialization but are
focused on like a decentralized trial
for a behavioral intervention and these
are also things that i think might be
really interesting for the community to
to fund and develop um but yeah very
somewhat agnostic to the actual
um let's say hallmark of of aging that
that is to be focused on
oh no thank you for that and so as a
researcher like what would um why would
a researcher choose to doubt as opposed
to going the more traditional routes of
getting funds especially maybe if they
were like less familiar with um the
technology
yeah i think the primary draw is the
difference between having
you know a community or not having a
community the the greatest
strength that veda dog gives to a
researcher is having a couple of
thousand people at this point i think
there's almost 2 000 people in the
discord that are really interested in
your work and want to support you and
who you have the opportunity to as a
researcher
actually engage
um in in sort of let's say a more open
science like conversation you have the
ability to check in with people have
community calls
all of a sudden there's this network
that's really interested in your work
and they're not necessarily driven by
the same endpoints that a vc or a
startup would be driven by so
i think if you
if you're an academic that is beginning
to create something that is looking more
like a product more like a drug that
needs to be brought to market your
funding sources change it's no longer
let's say in the united states nih
brands that are going to support you you
have this sort of translational gap
which i think locally colloquially
referred to as the valley of death in
biopharma where you basically go from
sort of drug discovery
to something that needs to come to
market and this gap is it's called the
valley of death because it's very hard
to fund it's where a lot of innovation
goes to die and the reason that it's
hard to fund is that you now need to
either as an academic create a startup
or you need to find maybe maybe a
company's licenses technology or you
need to let's say partner in a
co-development deal you don't really
have the capacity to use grant funding
sources to fund this
so i would say that a lot of academics
although
yeah maybe they're really interested in
furthering this technology don't
are in a position to or don't want to go
and leave their academic post and create
a startup company it's a completely
different path
and many of them are let's say
still some number of experiments short
from having a project or a piece of ip
that would be optimal for an out license
event or even a co-development deal and
this is the gap that beta dal is trying
to fill and so what we offer is
you know a a source of of funding where
instead of having you know a vc which
still serve arguably a very important
role in biotechnology um driven by again
different endpoints it's it's
again it's it's a it's a business in
essence
um
instead you have a community of people
who might have any number of of interest
in seeing this developed the main thing
that we're trying to optimize for in
vitadao isn't necessarily the the the
profitability but ensuring that these
technologies come to market so that they
actually end up having an impact on this
community of people people want to see
um yeah we want to move the needle on
aging in a way that is somewhat applied
and where in our lifetime there is some
ability to really implement the sort of
technologies that that are being funded
so i would say yeah i mean to summarize
it it's really to have a community of
people that you're working with and that
are funding your work and interested in
what you're doing as opposed to a bc
thank you yeah so as you said the
community is definitely i think what
makes speeds fall very unique in terms
of the funding space and i know that the
community having been on the discord
myself is growing in size and there's
always different conversations going on
and as part of the community there's
also things that you do in peterborough
beyond just the funding which is like
the journal clubs that you're doing and
so i was just wondering um do you have
any like future plans for um beats down
in general beyond just the funding and
on from that
like what kind of a long-term plans or
short-term plans do you have um for
future level
yeah so i mean also i'll touch on two
things so there's the on the funding
there's actually a couple of additional
experiments that are happening which is
we're partnering with git coin to do a
quadratic funding ground for longevity
this will be purely philanthropic uh
they won't be geared around ip and will
basically be they'll be like a matching
pool
where um some number of laboratories i
think we're shooting for like 30 to 40
laboratories will be uh receive funding
for projects that are not ip focused so
this is sort of more
an experiment with a grant funding
approach alongside another really cool
project that people should check out
called called bitcoin and then on the
other side of it it's going back to
these like sort of educational resources
and also creating a like yeah finding
strength in this decentralized community
so the journal clubs are one component
we're starting an interview series with
with academics and prominent opinion
leaders from the from longevity space
that i'm really excited about
we're also looking at
um yeah we have basically what is called
like a cycom working group so science
communications i think we want to do
more webinars more general educational
content for the community um but what's
really interesting is that like i mean
on any given day
someone can show up to the vdoc
community with an idea and rally people
behind them and then all of a sudden
vitadell starts doing this thing so i
mean the journal club happened because
really there was an md phd student
called nicholas who joined the community
and
yeah i thought it would be really cool
to start doing a journal club and this
is what's
this is what's really exciting about
these organizations for me it's it's not
so much that you know it's it's
all of the ideas and all of the things
that you know someone might bring to the
table that wouldn't that would be
somewhat difficult to implement in a
traditional company or in a traditional
organization
something to this call could join
vitadoll tomorrow and say come into the
group and say hey i'm really interested
i want to help the longevity working
group i'm happy to help you know source
projects or evaluate projects but also i
think would be really cool if we did you
know a really
in-depth hundred part series covering
all the genes that are involved in the
aging process
and you know in two days time they would
probably have another group of 10 or 15
people behind them helping helping them
to create these things and that sort of
agility and that ability to like iterate
and do things very quickly
is is very different from how companies
work like if you think about what
vitadao is
beta dolls existed for like 13 weeks
maybe 12 weeks obviously the planning to
create the organization happen you know
for some number of months before that
but in like a period of
six months time roughly you have you
know
some number of millions of dollars in a
community of 2 000 people that is spun
up around something and is now executing
on these things it's yeah that that to
me is what is exciting about the crypto
space it's this like rapid iterative
experimentation and this ability to yeah
bring a community together around
something that would be
difficult or impossible to do in a
traditional hierarchical sort of
organizational structure
exactly and it sounds like super
exciting to see it grossly big um but is
that the possibility though that it
could you know grow kind of out of
control and
um
that leaves some ability to keep track
of everything that's going on because
obviously the idea behind the
decentralization is that no one's like
effectively in control but do you need
some elements of control to kind of like
you know keep things on track
definitely and i mean this is something
yeah we've had dolls come with like a
huge number of challenges it's not that
easy to coordinate a huge group of
people and there are many things where
it's like
you know it wouldn't be valuable to have
600 people deciding on like where an
article should be published for example
like there's many small things that
you know you can see why management
teams exist and you can see why
bureaucratic structures exist so i think
it would be silly to think that like
all of these there's me you don't need
to reinvent the wheel here there are a
lot of reasons why having some structure
make sense and so to address that the
structure within vita dial is always
evolving as i mentioned before we have
these things called called working
groups
and some amount of autonomy
is vested into those working groups from
the community so for example
um you know it is expected that the
longevity working group is providing due
diligence on scientific research
projects to be able to guide the
community on what makes sense to fund
they don't have the ability to override
the community and execute
but they are constantly making
recommendations on on you know what
should be funded and why or if something
looks like it's a you know maybe a bit
scammy or not real science they would
advise the community not to vote on this
we also have an operations working group
which is basically tasked with trying to
to create structures to help all of the
contributors that are working on
vitadell be able to do a good job and
have some continuity between these
groups and avoid redundancy for example
so these are sometimes very simple
things like
setting up a crm system or having an air
table where bounties and tasks are
managed and you know some number of
those things are implemented and then
you see that like okay this is not
working well at all it's super chaotic
like how are we going to how do we
improve and then somebody comes in with
a better idea and the community trusts
that person to implement it so it's this
very
iterative
experimental process where over time
there are some let's say conventional
structures that form and you do learn a
bit from like the agile startup approach
but at the end of the day the the core
decision making and that you know
executive function lies within the
entire community um but yeah as you
rightfully said
huge number of challenges and you know i
think in you know in some number of
years we're going to be able to look
back and say that like
decentralized organizations are very
good at these things they're not so good
at these things um and you know it's an
experiment in a new type of structure to
to do this sort of thing exactly but i
think that the understanding i'm getting
is that these cell systems are kind of
adaptable and so the hope is that you'll
be able to find solutions and alter the
structure and so um one kind of like
more cliche question is um what does
your typical day look like being uh the
co uh like initiator of molecule and now
developing feta dial
yeah so i mean it's it it's it's a lot
of time spent in front of the computer
unfortunately like maybe more than i
would i would like to but it's yeah so i
mean molecule is a is a startup company
of which i'm the the co-founder and
we're at a point where we're we're
trying to scale quite rapidly we're
trying to create this marketplace for
ipfts a lot of the work is linked to
vitadao um because vitadao is really i
would say the first real world use case
for some of these technologies that
we've been developing
um and then yeah
was created by a community of people
right i'm one of i'm one of the people
who have have contributed to let's say
the creation of vita dial but there's
quite a few and i think there's this
forward feedback cycle happening where i
think i was
quickly identified early on as one of
the people and now being in a lot of
interviews and stuff but there's
actually a ton of amazing people from
that community that have played a really
crucial role in bringing the
organization to life and and also that i
think um
yeah on a day-to-day basis or doing a
lot of like in many cases more so than
me a lot of the the let's say nitty
gritty work of making the organization
function
the the challenge for me from like
what my day looks like at the moment is
being a part of these discord
communities that are across time zones
and and never stop so i mean it's i'm
trying to find ways to like make time
for exercise and also turn off my phone
at 11 o'clock at night maybe so i'm not
getting notifications these are like
some of the challenges that i think that
come with working with people in
singapore in california and the uk
um it's extremely globalized sort of
thing where
you know it's always somebody's core
working hours which is an interesting
challenge and i i think when you start
with these things it's super exciting
and you sort of always like i don't know
i want to be able to react to any
question that comes at any time but then
it's also like
yeah you can quickly get to a point
where you're like
very burnt out and yeah you feel like
you need a digital detox um but yeah at
the moment i wish you know it's not like
being in a
in a lab or anything anymore i'm sitting
at an office you know for molecule or at
home in front of my computer
in the metaverse in essence
cool no it definitely does sound
exciting though um and so kind of slide
something a bit from fleet about because
also you have a much better knowledge of
i don't know like blockchain technology
blockchain technology than i do i was
just wondering like besides visa dao and
using the technology to fundraise and
create these um
ip nfts that you mentioned what other
like applications of blockchain do you
foresee in terms of being able to help
with longevity either in research or
from like any more like personalized
therapeutics
yeah so there's a number of in the past
six months one of the probably the most
exciting i mean i don't know if it's a
calls and effects sort of thing but i
think one of the most exciting things
that i've been seeing is is other people
who have ideas for dolls reaching out to
us and saying like
hey we want to
build x or y and so for years dals were
sort of like
quite self-contained within the crypto
space meaning that it was like you know
dials were used to develop projects on
ethereum or govern a a protocol that a
blockchain was using you know i had a
call with someone the other day who
wants to create he's a geo engineer and
he wants to create a dial that's focused
on terraforming and is is basically
geared at aligning the academic
community
there's dowels that are focused on now
just open science and basically creating
like these almost open source
community-based research journals for
the publication of like negative results
there's people who are creating dowels
all of these all these organizations
like you know a dow can have any
structure right it doesn't need to be
based around intellectual property it
doesn't need to be like vitadao is a
very specific
design implementation of a dowel but you
could also create a dial that said hey
we're going to bring together
i don't know 100 people pull a certain
amount of money and just donate it to
two research projects or we're going to
create a dial that's focused on doing
you know you you could run a
decentralized trial for metformin via
dal so i think there's what we'll start
to see over over the next couple of
years in the longevity space and beyond
i i believe
is
you know this sort of um
this sort of rapid acceleration of of
these communities actually creating
these experiments that hopefully have an
impact on the longevity space and the
crypto space even beyond dallas is
playing an important role like i'm not
sure if you heard about there's a
project called impetus grants that was
just created in the longevity space
basically it's like 21 million dollars
that is going to be given it's like you
know the model of fast brands for
example it's like uh
yeah so fast grants was a was a program
that i think uh basically said that hey
we're going to we have a certain amount
of money we're going to make decisions
to fund grants or like it was mostly a
philanthropist that got together and
they were going if you have a project
idea we'll fund you within two weeks and
they did this in the context of covet
and i think they developed you know they
made quite a lot of progress in
developing like new testing approaches
and stuff like that this impetus grants
is a new approach to doing that for
longevity so it's 21 million dollars in
funding for for longevity research
there's no strings attached whatsoever
if you have a good idea and it's
interesting and it has to be early stage
basic research so something that's not
commercial commercially viable like sort
of high risk basic research uh you can
apply within two weeks they'll they'll
get you the money and this is really
interesting but you know the person who
funded that was uh the guy who created
ipfs which is the the basically a
storage network on on blockchain so
there's a huge amount of one of the
other really interesting things is that
there's a lot of people in crypto
um who have made a lot of money at this
point they've
yeah in some cases like someone
accidentally and so all of this funding
that exists i think is going to begin to
leave the crypto space to some extent
and start to be focused on things like
terraforming or space colonization or
longevity all these
things that are quite like
really capital intensive and it's not
clear who's going to pay for them and
that to me is like really exciting i
think dallas will play a big role of
this because those people who are
deploying their funding into these
spaces are going to want to make sure
that um you know it's decentralized
communities that are basically governing
how those funds are being spent
yeah it's good to hear because i mean
like it seems like now each week there's
always new news about um more uh funding
for longevity research like there was
even the news last weekend about otto's
labs which sounds very exciting
um yeah totally i think it's definitely
the best year for the space in terms of
funding and like the interest point is
incredible so hopefully we get to the
point of actually rescue like
reaching escape velocity in our in our
lifetimes
so you're talking yeah talking more
about the longevity research itself are
there any areas that you're most excited
about in terms of longevity research
yeah i mean so i have i have my own
biases i was always really interested i
mean i studied dna damage and repair and
i always thought this was really
interesting because i really liked the
idea of being able to prevent things
like mutation or for example like if we
were able to bolster our own endogenous
dna repair response it feels like there
was a tremendous amount of of damage
that we would be able to avoid and you
know maybe even to a certain extent be
able to avoid the the aging phenotype
that said i think it's you know that
field actually hasn't produced an
incredible amount of like
yeah tangible pharmacological targets or
something where i'm most interested from
a practical perspective perspective at
the moment is really around like
rejuvenation biotechnology
and replacements
one of the projects that i learned about
recently that i was
yeah i think most excited to hear about
was a project from jean bair at albert
einstein university which was focused on
brain cell replacement
he gave a talk to the foresight
institute if anyone's interested in
learning more about this project but i
think the core idea is that you know
most of your body
we already really have the technology to
recapitulate the function of or replace
many aspects many organ systems or
aspects of the body right so the heart
is a pump the lungs are a pump kidneys
you could sort of do with with with
dialysis machines for example the liver
is quite complex maybe that's a little
bit more difficult but ultimately that
the black box is the most difficult
thing to really
let's say uh fix would is the brain
right and so you have this i think even
if we were able to
even if we were able to
treat the aging phenotype in every other
aspect if we can't do the brain it all
becomes meaningless you could transplant
a brain into a cybernetic body and that
brain could still get alzheimer's for
example it's it's it's this really
challenging thing so you know there are
now projects being started that are
hyper ambitious that are looking at like
brain cell replacement therapy where you
would slowly begin to
to let's say replace
small parts of the
regions of the brain and allow the sort
of yeah
the neuroplasticity and these basically
to form and you know establish old
connections and over time you would be
able to like you know i forget what the
with the paradox is but it's the one
about replacing um
planks on a ship like if if you
eventually if you rebuild the ship by
replacing all of these wooden planks
since it's still the same ship at the
end of the day and this is sort of the
idea like the slow replacement of brain
cells and i really like this and i'm
generally interested in
i think rejuvenation biotechnology is
something that's accelerating quite a
lot and something that might be
accessible in our in our lifetime
exactly i think yeah there's so many
different areas now um it's like it's
hard to keep up with all of it i have to
say um but yeah there's definitely many
different exciting um avenues
and so um
just to kind of more wrap things up a
little bit um do you have any more
general advice about anyone wanting to
learn more about either blockchain
technology or advice about someone um
wanting to maybe start their own doubt
or start their own initiative that would
help to um well for any kind of reason
yeah so i mean i i think the cool thing
about dallas is they're yeah it's
actually relatively easy to start one
and the tooling is really advancing to a
point like there are some
organizations that are working on like
basically software that allows you to
launch your own dial like with a couple
clicks of a button these are still quite
early but i think in the next six months
it will
these technologies will begin to mature
quite a bit
i would say i mean the space is wide
open and it's also very playful it
doesn't have to be you can create you
know a very silly implementation of a
dial just to mess around or you can get
together with 10 or 20 friends and
launch your own token like the
blockchain space is like a giant sandbox
where anybody could basically go and
begin to experiment with an incentive
system or an idea i think that's why
it's attracted
you know a lot of people and why it's
also beginning to resonate more and more
with scientists it's this active area of
experimentation so i would i would
suggest anyone who's interested
check out dalstack check out the token
engineering commons there's a number of
discord communities that are open
they're really great people in them and
if you have an idea and you're
interested in building something you can
connect with other people and and find
out how to do this or find out how to
yeah how to help maybe you could learn
you know i think
if you one of the best skills you could
possibly learn right now is like
learning how to code solidity and write
smart contracts which are going to
become increasingly important over the
next years and then in terms of yeah in
terms of like um
the longevity community i think one of
the things that's interesting is that i
mean it is this really broad and
inclusive community if you join like the
longevity subreddit for example there's
like 100 000 people that are always
talking about this stuff
there's a
i mean family isn't the right word to
use but it really feels like this
collectivist sort of like uh very
inclusive and welcoming community and
and the blockchain space is the same
it's like
yeah if you want to build something and
you have an idea and people resonate
with that idea you could very quickly
get something going so yeah i would
strongly encourage anyone to check that
out
and more importantly how can anyone join
feeder dow what's the best way to do
that
yeah so the easiest way is to just join
our discord community it's listed on the
website it's relatively yeah you can
join it within a couple clicks of a
button um if you actually want to get
involved in the working groups there
everything is fully transparent so if
you're in the discord community you can
see longevity working group or
operations working group feel free to
reach out to any of the members in that
working group or the steward which will
be visible as well just to get involved
particularly if you're a researcher or
if you're an academic
there's a couple of ways that you can
get involved one is by helping directly
with these working groups i'm talking
about but we're also
you know we're really looking for
interesting projects to fund um yeah and
i would say that
yeah just a general call to researchers
if people have projects that you think
would be suitable we're
um funding up to 250 000 for for
longevity focused research projects and
if you have any interest in just being a
part of the community even just a fly on
the wall that's keen to observe how this
experiment is going please feel free to
yeah to join the discord community cool
so thank you tyler for coming on today
it's been great to hear more about feed
it out and the success you've had so far
and doing your first set of fundraising
and so it's you've made it kind of look
so easy but it's evidence from speaking
to you that there's been a lot of hard
work that goes on behind the scenes so
yeah thank you um for everything you've
done so far we're fleeted out and yeah
thanks again for coming on it's been a
really great conversation
yeah and thank you for for having me and
for the amazing show that you've you've
created this is yeah in terms of like
scientific content that exists and
taking complex things and simplifying i
think this is maybe the the best channel
that i've seen on on youtube so it was
really a pleasure to be on the show i
really admire the work that you're doing
thank you so i hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you